did you really smash up that executives
record or the record executives office
yeah don't feel good about that good
about that I do you know I mean I try
not to be a violent person and right
second car he just pushed me to the
limit and here's why you know um I had
sold a lot of Records with America's
Most Wanted and I think killers will and
I wanted an advancement on my next
record because O'Shea jr. was about to
be born
okay ain't there so I say man you know I
got a baby coming and I need to get out
of this apartment that I was in I want
to get a house for my family by the way
that's crazy when you talk about like -
like elastic albums right yes and
they're out and they've sold and like
it's not like people found them later
like those were giant albums yes and
you're like I'm gonna try to get out of
an apartment now I mean I was in the
apartment cuz I that was really my first
time being able to move out and do
anything so that was just my spot uh-huh
I was stacking money then but I was 100
grand short on this house
uh-huh because when you buy a house you
gotta have not only yo money but a
little extra money to give away for the
house so I was 100 grand short I said do
I need advancement on my record and I
mean give me advancement and uh you know
the album almost finished he was like
cool you know on the phone he's like
cool so when we went through escrow
I called him my yo escrow about the
clothes I'm a hundred G's short I need
that - I don't know what um I what I
don't never saying I would give you that
I was like dude don't play with me now
I'll never giving you that I said oh
okay I saw them on my way up there
terrible news yeah where is it sitting
with and uh I got up there and you know
I walk through they they saw me with a
bat so cute a man you don't call your
background
the other side we're buying that man in
there
so I go in his office now got the lynch
mob with me you know I got right you
know JD t-bone shorty we go in there and
he's in his bathroom in his office and
and so we you know of course in the
movie we walk in and it just happens
sure sure but in reality he was in the
bathroom and when he came out we was
just posted up in his office by the way
for Farah by I know that's the only
reason he didn't shoot himself yes come
out of it a half room otherwise oh hey
thank you
what's up what's going on like he didn't
know yeah Mike so he goes his desk and I
go and close the door and I want to go
now you can't leave and uh and I just
started braiding man and telling why
he's long and [ __ ] up for what he's
doing and I just got more heated and
heated and heated and then I was looking
at all these records and everything had
I was so fed up at this time with with
this paper-pushing
called a lawyer all this kind of this
was the world I didn't know right so I'm
like now I gotta take this back to South
Central if I said rearrange his office
point and uh and what they say when
you're smashing all of his [ __ ]
is he like this is the way to just uh
mom do what the TV come on talking about
all kind of things we break out and the
whole office is like what the hell just
happened now everybody looking at us
walk through we get on the elevator we
go down and it's like LAPD everywhere
freeze all this up against the wall we
up against the wall and and the the
other owner mark ceramic comes down he's
like kill what happened what's going on
I'm like man Brian he's messed up mumble
my telling me said man no charge can you
guys just leave them
we don't want to talk no charges for the
police back dog he's a kill call me
tomorrow man please I called him he
wrote me to check for 100 GS I got my
house yeah I said jr. didn't have to
grow up homeless and all thank you yeah
yeah we made up six months later uh-huh
you know and when I went back up there
though they had bulletproof glass
bulletproof glass this thick you have to
get buzzed in man keeps you and walk you
back and all this kind of stuff it was
crazy I know Sporting Goods either